country and rock music i feel like it
doesn't matter how old you are it's
definitely timeless i swear rap music i
feel like you know you're going to
always have a niche audience but
hip hop is all about what's new what's
next you know i was telling somebody
what i'm anxious to see
is the um
i watched
the mount westmore tour come to
nashville
and sell out the bridgestone arena
thirteen thousand seven hundred seconds
yep
and then i'll watch the legends of the
street tour come to nashville jeezy
gucci tv yeah sell our boots who sell
out 13 700 tickets
it's the first time in our in life that
we're seeing hip-hop translate
generationally right and like oldies
hip-hop for sure because like back in
the day that's what they'd say this will
never make it to arenas nobody will care
to see this show in 20 years
and people are seeing it
i want to see in 20 years from now if
little dirk
and little baby and the baby can go sell
15 000 tickets in every major market in
america right time will tell it's gonna
be fun to watch dude it's like a student
of the game because hip hop is so
young
when you think about it not even from
the kids doing it like just to think
that ice cubing them was our first
reference point of watching hip-hop grow
with people to the point that i just
watched 13 000 white kids it's like we
in their [ __ ] 40s what's singing
everywhere those guys are like are
they're
the first generation of hip-hop guys to
be 50. yeah
you know what i mean it's crazy right
yeah i didn't think about it till i was
there and i was like this is nuts yeah
like dude i was born when nwa was
getting active i was oh yeah i was born
in 87 yeah for sure so
i'm a little bit more than that but yeah
i was born a little bit more now
just a little bit not much not a ton of
hair
what's been like um
you know since you've kind of been on
this run the last couple of years what
has been the coolest thing that you've
got to experience because you've showed
out some big shows you've been a part of
like some crazy
you've just been i mean you're about to
do jimmy kimmel tomorrow you know like
what's been some something that's where
you just kind of had to pinch yourself
one of those moments we're like damn
this is pretty [ __ ] cool
uh
the first time that when we got invited
to the granola library um was just
the history of the grand ole opry and
i'm letting somebody that represents our
community and our kind
and our culture
you know because like regardless of how
much i mess the music together i'm a
hip-hop kid
and i'll always will be i'm a student of
the game i love hip-hop
and i was the first rapper to play the
grand ole opry even though i sung right
right it's like still there's a thing
there
um
the first local rapper because
nashville's had a lot of big talent come
out to sell out the ramen of course yeah
we're we are like
35 no [ __ ] tickets away from selling
out red rocks in october
so that's a that's in denver yeah you
got to come out october 23rd
it's going to be nuts you're headlining
that's going to be crazy yeah almost
sold out
and we're playing you know we're
headlining my arena in nashville you
seen this part you've seen that i saw it
yeah this is crazy so we're going to
headline that's another one that was
they're all wow moments yeah i saw that
big show you did last year in dallas and
look [ __ ] crazy insane no for sure we
just sold
7 000 tickets at a hockey arena sold out
in kalamazoo the day of the on sale that
[ __ ] man struggles just played it the
other day it was [ __ ] nuts i just did
20 000 people at tailgates and tall boys
co-headlining with riley
just every everything about us just like
what in the [ __ ] is happening what are
the things that you're noticing um
being in the country industry now
because it is you've lived in nashville
so i'm sure it's not it's never been too
far away but it's a different game like
i feel like country is one of the i know
people who do country radio
and they get treated like [ __ ]
royalty yeah by the artist and by by
like the labels it's crazy well
you know
people still buy cds people don't
realize countries still
the only cds getting sold at walmart if
country cds what i love about country
music is is it's very tribal
there's a lot of people who find music
through country radio and through the
just country music
it's like
there's still a country music fan
that exists it's like just a fan of
country music mm-hmm so if they know
that you do country music they're just
in they're gonna at least give you a
chance they're gonna give you a chance
they're like oh [ __ ] i love country
music you make country music play me
something yeah where it's like in
hip-hop it's like everybody raps
this is true every everybody everybody
raps trust me i just left an empire
brunch shout out to empire
bro i couldn't walk two feet with
someone stopping me and just
oh for sure it was just like hey yo i
rap yeah i get on the pod hey yo what's
up yo yo and you're just like
no it's there's a lot everybody raps so
it's like when you tell the dude hey man
i rap let me play you something instead
of them being like i'd like to listen
they go i rap too
and you're just like oh there that went
you know you know but you don't need a
lot of country artists
i mean unless you're in nashville in
nashville exactly you throw a rock and
hit one but it's like there's a core
country music fan
and i've always been a country music fan
just because you grew up in nashville
you can't help but to be
there's no way that yeah i mean country
i feel like um
obviously i'm a big hip-hop dude but
like
just like with any genre of music
there's [ __ ] i like right you know what
i mean you know halite said it to me
best
when this [ __ ] started working for me he
said
i'm watching you finally do what i
watched you
do in the car for 10 years he's like and
it's so gratifying
because we would get in the car and go
on these long road trips and i would
just torture them with
george strait records and billy
currington songs and i'm like blair like
i'm doing sound check singing darius
rucker every day that's [ __ ] great
you know and the highlight was like it's
so cool like everybody who really knows
what kind of music i listen to
thought it was super dope to finally see
me you know okay this is like you know
you doing what we see you do in the car
anyways like we watch you smoke weed and
sing alan jackson so this is cool